[Musique]
et aujourd'hui j'accueille même la
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire elisabeth bornes
bonjour elisabeth bord un beau show
alors nous sommes ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour évoquer beaucoup de sujets
importants et urgents
d'abord la phase ii du déconfinement qui
a été annoncé hier par le premier
ministre edouard philippe avec des
déplacements des français qui sont
désormais illimité ça y est on peut dire
que les français sont libérés oui je
crois que c'est le retour à une certaine
liberté
du fait de l'évolution encourageante 1
au plan sanitaire
c'est quand même une liberté qui reste
encadrée parce que le virus est toujours
là et donc il faut rester très attentif
continuer à faire preuve de beaucoup de
civisme en appliquant des mesures
barrières alors en même temps est bien
le premier ministre demande aux français
concernant les déplacements de non pas
de ne pas aller se déplacer à l'autre
bout de la france si ce n'est pas
nécessaire est ce que vous ne craignez
pas un effet de foule à partir du 2 juin
dans l'est dans les bars dans les
terrasses dans les parcs et jardins
je pense qu'on appelle vraiment chacun a
continué à montrer la même
responsabilité que ce que les français
ont montré pendant le confinement est
depuis la première phase du
déconfinement on est tous responsables
de l'évolution de cette épidémie
donc on est certainement content de
retrouver des libertés mais il faut
vraiment rester attentif resté 13 voilà
très vigilants et continuer à faire
preuve de civisme en respectant les
mesures barrières on a l'impression que
le véritable enjeu de cette phase 2 du
déconfinement c'est surtout de relancer
des activités comme le tourisme et la
culture qui sont lourdement frappée par
les effets de cette crise enfin l'enjeu
c'est aussi qu'on a tous envie de
retrouver la vie la plus normale
possible
et puis c'est vrai que avec la crise
sanitaire dont on voit que m l'activité
économique à l'arrêt comme c'est le cas
depuis des semaines évidemment ça
soulève des très gros sujet des très
gros problème et il faut que notre
économie aussi repartent c'est le retour
de notre liberté et puis la reprise de
l'activité économique pour qu'on n'ait
pas des conséquences sociales difficiles
pour tous les français alors votre
ministère est en charge des transports
à quoi vont ressembler nos transports en
commun
dans les prochains mois est ce que leur
capacité de remplissage va revenir alors
à la normale ce qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'effectivement la première phase du
déconfinement s'est bien passé on a
voulu être très stricte dans cette
première phase en réduisant
drastiquement la fréquentation grâce au
télétravail que les entreprises ont
continué à appliquer très fortement au
décalage des horaires et les opérateurs
de transport ont aussi distribué du gel
hydroalcoolique fait beaucoup de
marquage et donc on a également demandé
de porter un masque et moi je peux voir
aujourd'hui que près de 95 % des ceux
qui empruntent et transports en commun
ou un masque d autres sont sanctionnés
donc du coup on peut on va pouvoir à
partir de la semaine prochaine puisque
tout le monde porte un masque accepté à
certaines heures une fréquentation plus
importante et permettre du coup
d'accompagner la reprise de l'activité
économique
mais justement on va parler de cette
situation économique et notamment du
plan de restructuration du constructeur
automobile renault qui devrait être
annoncée aujourd'hui avec quinze mille
suppressions de postes dans le monde
dont 4600 en france et notamment des
départs volontaires
elisabeth bande est ce que vous
confirmez qu'il n'y aura pas de
licenciements secs chez renault alors
peut-être d'abord dire 1 qu' on est dans
un secteur qui en grande difficulté et
pendant le confinement il n'y a
quasiment pas eu une voiture de vendus
donc quand en plus on avait un
constructeur qui avait déjà annoncé la
nécessité de faire des économies avant
la crise donc on est face à un
constructeur qui en grande difficulté
c'est bien pour ça que le président de
la république a présenté en début de
semaine un plan de soutien massif pour
sauver le secteur 1 8 milliard d'euros
pour sauver le secteur en accélérant sa
transition écologique et ça passe à la
fois par un développement massif de la
production de véhicules électriques en
france on veut que ces véhicules qui
sont l'avenir de l'automobile soit
produit chez nous et en même temps on
veut relancer d'activité en aidant les
français à acheter ces véhicules
électriques mais néanmoins il ya
effectivement
il faut que renault puisse surmonter ses
difficultés et préparer l'avenir donc
des dirigeants de renault présenteront
tout à l'heure leur plan évidemment on a
été très attentif
en contrepartie des aides qui sont
importés à ce que l'inattention très
forte portée à l'emploi effectivement
renault a indiqué qui aurait pas de
licenciements secs donc que des départs
volontaires et des non remplacements
c'est des départs naturels et voilà donc
c'est des discussions qui vont se mener
au sein de renault mais je peux vous
assurer que le gouvernement le président
de la république sont très attentif à
ces sujets d'emploi faut permettre à
renault de préparer son avenir mais en
soutenant notamment l'avis de véhicules
électriques comme on le fait avec
l'augmentation du bonus on donne aussi
des débouchés des marchés à renault et
de la production de véhicules
électriques en france
alors l'état reste vigilant mais est-ce
que des usines renault vont fermer dans
ce plan de restructuration
je vais laisser des dirigeants de
renault présenté leur plan ce qui est
important c'est vraiment que on veut
développer enfin vous savez ça fait des
années unc les constructeurs automobiles
ont délocalisé de la production en
dehors de france
là on veux plus de délocalisations on
veut au contraire développer de la
production renault s'est engagé à
multiplier par trois les la production
de véhicules électriques d'ici 2022 à
développer son nouveau moteur électrique
en france c'est des engagements qui sont
importants c'est les emplois de demain
un mot justement sur la voiture
électrique et sur l' usine de flins sur
seine dans les yvelines qui produisait
la voiture renault à zoé voiture
électrique
quel va être l'avenir de cette usine je
vais pas me prononcer mois sur l'avenir
de l'île usine de flins par contre je
peux me prononcer sur l'avenir de la
voiture électrique qu'on veut absolument
développer savait depuis depuis le
départ depuis que moi je suis au
gouvernement
je m'attache à développer des solutions
alternatives à la voiture a développé
des mobilités actives partout où c'est
possible mais aussi beaucoup de français
dans des territoires qui n'ont pas
d'alternative à la voiture et là on veut
les accompagner pour passer à des
voitures électriques quand c'est
possible et au moins à des véhicules
plus propres et c'est vraiment le sens
de l'augmentation du bonus qu'on a
annoncé en début de semaine puisqu'on va
passer de 6000
7000 euros donc c'est le moment
d'acheter une voiture électrique
d'autant que par ailleurs on a une prime
à la conversion pour remplacer un vieux
véhicule
et là vous pouvez avoir 5000 euros de
plus on pouvait avoir une aide 12000
euros de l'état pour passer à
l'électrique donc c'est maintenant alors
de véritables investissements
stratégiques vous le disiez il y a les
effets de la crise sur l'activité du
constructeur renault
mais avant cela il ya une erreur de
stratégie selon vous enfin moi je vais
pas commenter la stratégie de renault ce
matin ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
c'est un constructeur qui s'est engagé
très tôt dans le véhicule électrique
c'est l'avenir de l'automobile
il faut qu'on l'aide dans une période
qui est difficile pour accélérer sa
transition écologique vous savez cette
façon générale ce qu'on fait en sortie
de crise je pense qu'il faut accélérer
la transition écologique ça sera
évidemment indispensable pour répondre à
la crise écologique qui est là malgré la
crise sanitaire
et c'est comme ça qu'on va créer des
emplois la transition écologique c'est
beaucoup d'emplois dans la rénovation
énergétique dans la mobilité électrique
dans le recyclage
et voilà c'est vraiment la logique de
sortie de crise accélérer la transition
écologique une dernière question sur
renault est ce que l'alliance avec le
japonais nissan est en danger on parle
notamment d'un rapprochement avec
l'allemand daimler
je peux vous dire que cette alliance je
pense qu'elle a rarement eu autant de
contenu est face à une crise comme celle
que connaît le constructeur c'est le
moment où ils resserrent les liens pour
mieux se partager les rôles et c'est
comme ça que effectivement renault va
garantir son avenir un avenir sur une
mobilité propre
alors on va parler d'un autre fleuron de
l'industrie française de l'industrie
aérienne le groupe air france qui est
également frappée par cette crise du
coronavirus avec un plan de départs
volontaires qui est attendu il pourrait
y avoir des licenciements chez air
france écoutez j'ai pas non plus je
faisais ça relève du dialogue social je
pense que ce qui est important c'est
qu'on a dû soutenir là aussi la
compagnie air france on a un prêt
garanti de l'état de 7 milliards d'euros
évidemment on a demandé des
contreparties des engagements dans
l'emploi sur la transition écologique et
évidemment d'être très attentif aux
salariés mais sur la transition
écologique vous avez vu qu'en
contrepartie de l'aide renault s'est
engagé à réduire de 50 % ses émissions
de co2 sur ses vols en france
donc c'est un engagement absolument
inédit qui passe aussi par le fait de
réduire drastiquement les liaisons
quand on a un trajet alternatif en train
à moins de 2h30
donc c'est toute la philosophie je pense
de cette sortie de crise de se dire
qu'évidemment on aide les secteurs qui
sont en difficulté et on en profite pour
accélérer la transition écologique juste
donc pas de garanties sur l'emploi chez
air france je pense que je vous dis
c'est pas moi qui vais faire le
l'annoncent des plans d'air france
évidemment si on développe davantage le
train plutôt que l'avion sur des
liaisons à moins de 2h30
il faudra qu'on trouve des solutions
pour les salariés ça peut se faire aussi
avec les autres modes et avec le voilà
en profitant du développement des tgv à
la place des liaisons aériennes et
justement vous parliez des garanties
écologiques d'air france en échange du
plan de soutien de l'état il pourrait y
avoir
et bien la fermeture de liaisons
intérieures entre paris et certaines
métropoles régionales comme bordeaux
nantes et lyon c'est une contrepartie
notamment pour favoriser le
développement du tgv
ces garanties écologiques elles vont
frapper de plein fouet des aéroports
régionaux comme bordeaux et lyon je
pense que à un moment donné il faut
aussi un peu de cohérence 1 on nous
demande de réduire on doit réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et on
doit le faire parce que on a une crise
écologique qui est aussi devant nous je
pense que les français qui viennent de
vivre la crise sanitaire
ils ont pas envie quand les expose à une
crise climatique dont on voit déjà les
effets un la canicule l'été dernier les
inondations donc on doit absolument
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre faut évidemment qu'on s'assure que
toutes les villes en france les
métropoles n'y a pas que des métropoles
en france continue à être bien connecté
c'est indispensable pour développer
l'emploi dans les territoires donc on va
y veiller mais en même temps il faut
aussi tenir ce cap de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre s
conséquent ces lignes intérieures au der
france vont fermer
d'abord vous avez noté qu'elle y en a
beaucoup qui sont arrêtés donc je pense
que la france va réfléchir au moment de
relancer son activité à la façon dont il
relance ou non certaines liaisons
mais c'est aussi des choses qui vont se
faire évidemment en concertation en
discussion avec les élus des territoires
concernés
et oui on him as it on imagine qu'il ya
des tensions sur ce point avec les élus
locaux
évidemment les élus ils vont être
attentif et c'est bien légitime à ce que
leur territoire reste connecté aux
autres territoires en france à l'europe
c'est indispensable pour développer
l'emploi dans ces territoires donc ces
discussions elles doivent se mener avec
air france est évidemment gouvernement
sera attentif à ce qu'on apporte des
bonnes réponses dans chacun des
territoires
un mot sur la filière aéronautique
notamment sur le groupe airbus le
gouvernement est en train de préparer
son plan de soutien à la filière
aéronautique est ce qu'on connaît déjà
les axes de ce plan de soutien notamment
sur l'investissement et l'innovation
alors moi je peux vous dire que les axes
sur l'innovation ils sont très claires
c'est d'accélérer pour arriver et quand
je dis ça dit parfois que ça n'est pas
voilà que ça n'est pas crédible à un
avion zéro carbone d'ici 2035 et d'ici
là de développer des motorisations
hybrides
je pense que là encore la crise elle est
sans doute l'occasion pour notre filière
aéronautique de prendre de l'avancé
d'être leader de l'avion zéro carbone et
c'est ce type de recherche que l'état va
aider et qu'elle sera l'enveloppent
budgétaires pour soutenir la filière et
je pourrai revenir vous en parlait en
tout cas voilà le cap
il est clair réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et bien vous serez
la bienvenue pour en reparler
on va maintenant parler de la relance
économique d'une manière générale pour
éviter la casse sociale dans les
entreprises quelle doit être la place de
l'écologie dans cette relance économique
en france
vous aurez compris que je considère
qu'elle doit être centrale je pense que
la transition écologique dans cette
sortie crise c'est la meilleure
stratégie à la fois pour protéger les
français
d'autres crises des crises climatiques
des crises écologiques et c'est aussi
une façon de créer de l'emploi
je pense qu'il faut avoir en tête quand
après la crise de 2008 on avait loupé le
redémarrage en a sans doute pris dix ans
de retard
à l'époque mais aujourd'hui on a des
technologies qui sont matures et des
entreprises beaucoup de secteurs
économiques qui sont engagés dans la
transition écologique
s'ils ont changé de cap alors là on
perdrait tout le monde
au contraire il faut accélérer pour
créer de l'emploi dans la rénovation des
bâtiments voyez moi je souhaite qu'on
puisse accélérer sur la reine
version thermique des hôpitaux des ehpad
des écoles des logements je pense qu'on
peut aussi développer de la mobilité
propre
on en a parlé qu'il faut aussi investir
sur la réparation le recyclage et ce
sont des emplois beaucoup d'emplois dans
tous les territoires souvent non
délocalisables et il ya quelques jours
vous avez écrit aux patrons des grandes
entreprises françaises pour leur
demander des engagements écologiques
dans la relance économique du pays
est-ce qui vous ont répondu est-ce qu'il
va y avoir une réunion avec eux au
ministère alors pour refaire l'histoire
pour vous ré explique effectivement moi
j'ai vu une tribune qui a été publiée
par près de 100 dirigeants de grandes
entreprises françaises qui appelle à ce
que la transition écologique soit au
coeur de la sortie de crise et qui
disent être prêts à s'engager
donc avec ce courrier que je leur ai
adressé moi je leur dis chiche
maintenant le moment est venu de de
concrétiser de donner du corps à cette
tribune et donc de prendre des
engagements
donc j'ai eu beaucoup d'échangés
évidemment avec les différents
dirigeants qui ont signé la tribune on
est en train de caler la façon dont ils
pourront venir au ministère pour
présenter leur engagement écologique à
la fois des engagements je dirais de
moyen terme comment ils vont contribuer
à notre objectif d'être neutre en
carbone en 2050
et puis des choses très concrètes
notamment pour les salariés comment on
facilite le vélo pour les salariés
comment on est en place le forfait
mobilité durable pour encourager le
covoiturage et le vélo comment on
développe le bio dans la restauration de
ces entreprises
donc moi j'attends des engagements très
concret je convaincu qu'ils auront à
coeur de répondre à ce courrier est
justement sur la restauration
d'entreprise
il pourrait y avoir un jour végétarien
chaque semaine dans les cantines
d'entreprise alors vous savez c'est ce
que l'état applique pour ses propres
cantine et je pense que c'est bien c'est
une façon aussi d'avoir va de tirer une
alimentation plus équilibrée et puis le
bio c'est une façon de tirer une
agriculture plus durable
donc je pense que ça serait bien
effectivement c'est en tout cas ce que
j'attends de ces entreprises qu'elles
s'engagent
de la même façon alors on va parler du
nucléaire rapidement puisqu'il hier au
sénat le président de l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire a assuré qu' edf
faisait preuve
site d'un manque de rigueur dans
l'exploitation des centrales nucléaires
notamment dans le domaine de la sécurité
quelle mesure vous comptez prendre pour
remédier à ce manque de rigueur en
termes de sécurité
alors je pense que le président de l'asn
est dans son rôle de pointe et toutes
les améliorations qui sont possibles
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui je mangeais
beaucoup des changes avec lui puisque on
doit recalé le programme des maintenance
des centrales nucléaires qui n'ont pas
pu se faire pendant la période et je
pense qu'ils les voient la tf a bien
reçu les messages qui lui ont été
adressés et ils sont vraiment très
mobilisés je pense que le président de
l'asn a dit aussi ya pas de risque sur
la sûreté nucléaire
mais on doit pouvoir faire mieux et je
suis convaincu que c'est ce que edf va
s'attacher à faire
donc pas d'inquiétude sur la sûreté des
centrales non vous savez ça c'est
quelque chose avec lequel on ne transige
pas alors parlons du vélo vous avez
évoqué la pratique du vélo dans les
entreprises est ce que cette crise du
coronavirus c'est toute la réflexion sur
le monde d'après va mettre un coup
d'accélérateur au développement du vélo
c'est ce que je souhaitais et c'est ce
qu'on est en train de voir vous avez vu
que pour préparer la sortie du
confinement
les collectivités se sont mobilisés on a
eu mille kilomètres de pistes cyclables
30 temporaires qui ont été créés et moi
j'ai voulu permettre à tous les français
de pouvoir se remettre au vélo donc on a
créé un coup de pouce de 50 euros qui
prend en charge une partie de la
réparation de votre vélo donc à hauteur
de 50 euros
et ça connaît un succès absolument
incroyable depuis le 11 mai il ya
soixante dix mille vélos qui ont été
réparés donc j'ai annoncé qu'on allait
tripler le montant de l'enveloppé qui
était prévu initialement pour viser un
million de vélos réparé d'ici la fin de
l'année donc je pense que c'est un
engouement qui est certainement liée à
la sortie de crise
mais je suis convaincu que c'est quelque
chose de durable et on est en train
finalement quelques semaines de gagner
des années de politique vélo
moi je m'en réjouis parce que c'est un
mode de déplacement qui est facile qui
est écologique qui est bon pour le
porte-monnaie ça coûte pas cher et qui
est bon pour la santé mais vous vous
engagez également pour faire la
promotion de la pratique du vélo pour
les français mais moi je n'arrête pas de
faire la promotion de la pratique du
vélo
et vous suffit pas de voie là de faire
des grandes déclarations vive le vélo
c'est répondre c'est vraiment créer un
écosystème favorable donc permettre à
chacun d'avoir un vélo donc de le faire
réparer celui qui dormaient dans votre
garage ou dans votre cave c'est aussi
veiller à ce qu'ils aient des
stationnements sécurisés le vol du des
vélos c'est un point noir un qui peut
faire hésiter beaucoup de français donc
on crée des stationnements sécurisés en
tout cas on accompagne les collectivités
pour le faire on donne des formations
pour ceux qui sont pas très à l'aise
pour se remettre en selle c'est tout cet
ensemble est par ailleurs on est en
train de créer des emplois aussi dans la
réparation du vélo ont fait une académie
des métiers du vélo et dès cet été on
veut former 250 réparateur de plus parce
que quand vous discutez avec les parades
réparateur de vélos en france là ils
sont débordés ils n'ont jamais vu ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle aussi donc il
faut répondre vraiment à chacun des
maillons pour qu'on ait une nation vélo
que cette crise nous permettent
d'accélérer sur le vélo mais il avait
bornes devraient finir par des questions
politiques et ce coup de théâtre dans la
campagne municipale lyonnaise puisque
gérard collomb a renoncé à la course à
la présidence de la métropole de lyon et
il conclut une alliance avec la droite
est ce que vous comprenez ce choix une
alliance notamment pour faire barrage
aux écologistes
écoutez évidemment je le comprends pas
je pense que on parle souvent de
dépasser les clivages mais ça veut pas
dire accepter tous les arrangements en
l'occurrence des alliances avec les
candidats de laurent wauquiez
ça n'est pas du tout l'adn dans marche
on n'est pas du tout sur les mêmes
valeurs
donc moi je je je me réjouis que notre
mouvement est décidé d'engager la
procédure pour retirer l'investiture aux
candidats qui est désormais soutenu par
les amis de laurent wauquiez
en fait on ne partage pas les mêmes
valeurs et voiliers
faire accéder au pouvoir ou garder le
pouvoir ça ne doit pas permettre ça ça
faut pas passer par toutes ces
arrangements enfin c'est comme ça que la
politique se perd donc voilà je pense
que maintenant le candidat fin j'espère
que cette procédure de retrait de
l'investiture avance rapidement est ce
que gérard collomb doit encore rester à
la république en marche selon je pense
que je le dis clairement faire des
alliances avec les amis de l'enfant au
pied ça n'est pas en marche
ce n'est pas l'adn dans marché n'est pas
en marche un mot sur les municipales à
paris notamment sur la candidature
d'agnès busin au second tour elle s'est
excusée à propos est bien de ses
déclarations sur je cite la mascarade du
premier tour
est-ce que la candidature d'aînesse
busan peut vraiment gagner paris au
second tour écoutez je pense que c'est
important on attendait qu'elle confirme
sa candidature maintenant c'est fait ça
permet à tous ses colistiers de se
mettre en ordre de marche pour ce second
tour
elle porte un très beau projet et moi je
suis sûr qu'il ya beaucoup de parisiens
qui vont être convaincu par ce projet
qui est très écologique donc maintenant
voilà cette campagne elle peut repartir
et d'ailleurs notamment localement il y
a déjà des alliances entre eux l air em
et les républicains voulaient souhaitez
écouter là encore un mois je vous dis
que des personnes venant de tous les
horizons de droite comme de gauche
puissent se retrouver derrière le projet
de la république en marche c'est très
bien et là pour le coup c'est dans l'adn
du mouvement mais par contre là encore
des alliances avec rachida dati moi je
ne partage absolument pas la vision de
la ville que porte rachida dati qui
serait un retour en arrière donc pas
d'alliance avec rachida dati là non plus
merci beaucoup
elisabeth borne d'avoir été notre invité
politique ce matin sur le plateau de
bonjour chez vous